lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
demostrarles que los ángulos opuestos
por un vértice son iguales y para eso me
voy a tomar un par de líneas me voy a
tomar esta línea de aquí y esta línea de
acá si se dan cuenta se forman cuatro
ángulos ahora voy a ponerle nombre a los
puntos que voy a seleccionar a ver este
es el punto c este es el punto d y este
de aquí va a ser el punto y bueno ahora
me voy a tomar un ángulo arbitrario voy
a trabajar con el ángulo cp cbf y con el
ángulo cb voy a trabajar y yo lo que
quiero hacer es demostrarles que el
ángulo cb es igual al ángulo de b
bueno entonces vamos a escribirlo para
que no se nos olvide atrás de que
andamos
yo quiero probar o demostrar que el
ángulo cb es demostrar que el ángulo se
ve o que la medida más bien del ángulo
se ve que de hecho para no confundirnos
más mejor le voy a quitar la m de medida
y lo que yo quiero probar es que el
ángulo se ve la medida de ese ángulo es
la misma
que el ángulo debe a que el ángulo debe
am y si yo logro probar esta igualdad
entonces ya cabe la demostración porque
el ángulo cb y el ángulo de bea son
opuestos por el vértice y además eran
ángulos arbitrarios así que para
realizar esta prueba primero hay que
fijarnos en lo que sabemos yo sé que el
ángulo de bs y el ángulo se ve son
ángulos suplementarios es decir suman
180 grados entonces vamos a escribirlo
el ángulo se ve el ángulo cb y el ángulo
de bs son suplementarios ya que son
ángulos adyacentes y sus lados externos
forman una línea recta y bueno si son
suplementarios entonces el ángulo se ve
más el ángulo
dv se suman 180 grados muy bien voy a
ponerles un poco de color para no
olvidar quienes quiero que sean iguales
quiero que este ángulo el cbm sea igual
voy a cambiar de color al ángulo de vea
al ángulo de b
bueno que otra cosa sabemos que el
ángulo de vea y el ángulo de bc y el
ángulo de bbc también son suplementarios
forman un ángulo llano y además son
adyacentes es decir sus es decir sus
lados opuestos forman una línea recta y
bueno ya sabemos que si son
suplementarios entonces el ángulo debe
ha sumado o agregado al ángulo de bc nos
dan 180 grados es decir un ángulo llano
y bueno ahora de la igualdad que yo
tengo aquí arriba de este vuelta de aquí
yo lo que voy a hacer es restar de ambos
lados el ángulo de bs entonces me va a
quedar que el ángulo cb es igual a 180
grados menos el ángulo de pecém lo que
hice fue despejar al ángulo cb en esta
ecuación de aquí es la misma que la
ecuación que tengo yo aquí abajo ahora
bien de la ecuación que tengo en este
lado esta ecuación de aquí lo que voy a
hacer es lo mismo restar de ambos la
ecuación el ángulo de bbc por lo tanto
me va a quedar que el ángulo de bea es
igual a 180 grados ya esto hay que
restarle el ángulo de bc y por lo tanto
acá vamos a ver que el ángulo cb es
igual a 180 menos el ángulo de bbc y el
ángulo de bea es igual a 180 menos el
mismo ángulo de bc dos cosas que son
iguales a una tercera son iguales entre
sí por lo tanto el ángulo cb y el ángulo
debe a como son iguales
los 180 grados menos el ángulo de vc
entonces son iguales qué es lo que
queríamos probar el ángulo se ve el
ángulo de vea bueno bueno
la medida del ángulo se ve y la medida
del ángulo de a son iguales y con esto
terminamos la demostración pero más aún
como probamos que han ángulos
arbitrarios entonces este ángulo de aquí
y este ángulo de acá como son opuestos
por el vértice entonces también son
iguales
yo prefiero marcarlos con colores pero
muchos libros de texto lo que hacen es
usar la siguiente anotación ponen este
ángulo y este otro ángulo y para
distinguirlos de los ángulos originales
los cruzan y observen que como son
ángulos opuestos por un vértice también
son iguales esta demostración estuvo muy
padre pues me tomé dos líneas cualquiera
solamente que se cruzarán en un punto y
acabo de probar que sus ángulos opuestos
por un vértice son iguales este ángulo
de aquí era igual a este ángulo de acá
usando solamente el conocimiento que ya
teníamos de ángulos suplementarios